hey guys I had a question about
intermittent fasting and when to
exercise okay so let's just talk about
this for a second you know the whole
goal is to drain out the excess fat that
you have right other goals would be just
to feel better and get fit but maybe
mainly people want to lose weight and so
they'd start adding in a minute fasting
ketosis and they start adding these
things typically the big mistake is
adding too many things too fast in other
words trying to go to two meals a day
run off the bat and exercising on top of
it and they crash and burn so I think
the the ideal indicator to know if
you're doing it right is how you feel
when you start to exercise and you
actually go through it your legs heavy
do you feel tired do you feel like I
can't go on or do you feel like you have
to reserve it you can do it that's the
best indicator to know that you're being
able to handle it as far as the timing
goes I don't suggest if you're doing
cardio or interval interval training to
do it early in the morning if you're
going to wait if you're in the fast
period because you're going to deplete
your glycogen Reserve and if you're not
ready for it you have to adapt to it
you're going to feel you're going to get
really hungry okay and you're going to
feel light-headed hypoglycemic type
reaction so I always recommend doing the
exercise unless here really really fit
just before the meal during the the
eating period okay between the first and
second meal the first second and third
meal or just like me I exercise right
after the the last meal of the day okay
that's perfect because you have the
glycogen reserve you have the food there
to satisfy so you have the energy to
work out okay now this is are you going
to burn more fat verses here versus here
there's a couple studies and you can
burn a little bit more fat if you
workout in the evening because of the
the sleep cycles okay it's not that
significant so but it's a little bit
more some people need to add more
protein when they workout like they're
not doing any any protein at all so when
you workout you break down your protein
you're supposed to build up if you don't
have the amino acids if you don't have
the protein there you can feel a little
bit weird
so you want you may want to adjust the
protein a little bit or even add a meal
if you feel really kind of ravenously
hungry and you can't handle your just
going too fast okay
that's all so some people add creatine
okay so which is a it's a it's a
supplement that you can add to improve
recovery I like it
it's good if you want to actually
improve your recovery if you're trying
to maybe develop more muscle mass you
can add that and it doesn't necessarily
have to be with the meal okay I hope
that answered that question and put your
comments below hi guys hey listen I
created a pretty amazing evaluation quiz
down below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms
the most likely cause so take the quiz
now and we'll send you report